ciao nonna io esco così esce senza una
giacca senza un ombrello madonna fa
caldo c'è il sole il vento soffia da est
e gli uccelli volano molto marzo sai
cosa significa questo
no che tra poco viene giunti luvi
universale la nonna ci sono 30 gradi
[Musica]
cosa ti abbiamo attento può non sa vive
su questa terra da molto più tempo di te
e se dico carillon e nonna nonna
racconta mi del periodo della guerra
eravamo nel bel mezzo della guerra senza
cibo senza assolti e senza niente allora
tua nonna prende coraggio e va a parlare
direttamente sai con chi fu chi
convenuto muscio kit arrivo ieri di
kobenni e lui e poi mi sono svegliato
amore vabbè che sono vecchia ma io sono
una tantum ma io lo racconto faccio
tutti i miei compagni che hai fatto la
guerra
ma cosa vuoi che sia ma cosa fai di
sopra scendi subito da quella scala ma è
pericolosa la tua età pericoloso ma non
ha fatto delle salite così a 3000 metri
solo per andare a mungere le buche e
sfamare la famiglia sta roba cui uno
passeggiano piuttosto preoccupati per te
e alla tua età è già la coppa non c'è
neanche camminare dritto marina viene
accendere la tv che si è spenta io non
avrei sicuramente toccato per sbaglio il
tasto rosso non ho toccato niente guarda
mi sono seduta e basta non ascolta mi
prendi il telecomando e schiaccia il
pulsante rosso
io lo sai che non sa usare quella roba
lì non lo so usare ma guarda se non mi
vuoi aiutare va bene così basta basta
vorrà dire che massimo domani muoio
senza sapere sera il mondo veramente
figlia di pablo ma cosa dice ascolta
adesso arrivo aspetta un attimo ci sai
cosa faccio adesso
adesso me ne vado in ospizio lì
sicuramente se mi si spegne la tv ci
sarà qualcuno che mi avrebbe aiutato
vedrete mela accenderà hai capito ma ci
guarda proprio deciso me ne vado
salutami tua mamma ea te annuisci finta
di niente
e mentre fatto che ti dico continuando a
guardare che fa albinati grande anche il
fondo schiena e poi preleva la banconota
da 100 posti li infilano cemente opposto
dove nessun abbonamento non deve destare
sospetti perche si scoprono che nottata
che vogliono tutti oggi condurci tutta
cos'è stai male
sì non ho tantissimo mal di pancia
faccia mal di pancia cosa posso darti
per fare troppi celo celo guarda la mia
trisavola me lo faceva sempre con loro
mal di pancia che lo faccia subito altro
fa passare guarda ecco pronto ma che
cos'è cosa ci ho messo dentro allora è
un bel cucchiaino di miele scelto in
piazza di più pd cav hanno ancora
tiepida baby di cosa no no no no ma
guarda sto benissimo
vai tranquillo guarda che è buonissimo
noter accorge neanche e naturale